In this section, we will go over the final fitting process before DNA calibration is
used.
We will go over how to assemble and prepare the assets for fitting.
In the following section, we will continue with best practices for the final fitting
process.
The goal of the fitting process is to get the head geometry and the additional assets
fitted as close to the target delta as possible.
In by downloading the source assets of your character from the Quixel Bridge standalone
application.
Then assemble the necessary geometry for the final fitting process.
If you would like to inspect the assets in the Maya scene I will be showing, it is located
in the source files folder of our course, inside of the atomic savage folder, in the
folder named Modeling Assets.
Now let's jump into Maya to review the assets.
Inside of the Maya scene named Atomic S01 fitting, over here on the left in the Outliner
you will find all of the assets that have been used for this character.
The first group over here named Original Metahuman Creator contains the Atomic Savage head geometry
assembled from the source assets.
This includes the head LOD2 and LOD0 along with all of the LOD0 additional assets.
I'm going to bring the head mesh closer to view to show you that for this version the
region influence has been used on the eye area.
In the Outliner, right below this there is a version of the head geometry that demonstrates
what the polygon flow of the eye area looks like without using the region influence.
Now let's take a look at the original ZBrush head sculpt.
Over here in this group named ZBrush Initial Fitting, this mesh here is the original head
sculpt and here we have the version that the Metahuman Topology has been fitted to.
This asset is the target delta.
Now the assets that would need to be assembled in a new Maya scene include the fitted mesh,
this here is a copy of it and I will hide it for now along with all of these right below
that I am selecting.
These assets include the head LOD0 mesh and the head LOD2 mesh.
The LOD2 mesh is used for easier fitting and manipulating polygons.
Then we have all of the LOD assets which include the teeth, the saliva, the eye shell, the
eye right, the eye left, the cartilage, the eyelashes and the eye edge.
Finally over here we have a copy of the left and right eye.
With the assets assembled, the next step is to prepare these assets for the final fitting
process.
I am going to hide the fitted head until we meet it.
Something to note is that the following steps I will show have already been performed but
I will go through them in order to demonstrate what this process looks like.
So let's begin by preparing these assets for fitting.
The first step is to wrap all of the additional assets and the head LOD2 to the head LOD0
mesh.
To do this, select head LOD2 and all of the additional assets first, then select LOD0.
Next go up here to deform, then go to wrap and open up the wrap options.
Leave everything at default and select apply.
As mentioned, these steps have already been performed, I am just demonstrating these for
you.
The second step is to blend shape the head LOD and wrapped assets to the fitted head.
To do this I will unhide the fitted head mesh.
Now select the fitted head mesh first and then select head LOD0 that everything has
been wrapped to, then go up here to deform and go to blend shape and open up the blend
shape options.
Leave everything at default and apply.
Now if I press G to bring up the shape editor, we can use the slider to inspect the result
of the blend shape.
As a best practice, select all of these assets and then go to mesh display up here and select
unlock normals and then select soften edge.
Now I am going to hide the fitted head again.
If we inspect these assets, such as the eye shell, I will bring this closer to view.
These will need to be adjusted vertex by vertex to the fitted head mesh.
I am going to hide the eye shell and select the right and left eye.
These have been warped from the wrapping process, hence this is why we keep a copy of the eyes.
If you wish to inspect the final fitted assets, they are in the group labeled final fitted
head additional geo.
Now we have just gone over the assembly and preparation process for the final fitting
process.
Let's do a quick review of the steps we just covered before moving on.
The goal of the final fitting process is to fit the metahuman identity solve and its
additional head geometry assets to the fitted LOD0 head mesh.
To get started, begin by assembling the assets that will be needed for the final fitting.
Download the source assets from the Quixel Bridge standalone application and assemble
the head geometry in a new scene.
The meshes include the original LOD0 head mesh of the 3D model which is the target delta,
and the metahuman identity solve, the LOD2 head mesh and the LOD0 head mesh along with
all of the additional LOD0 head geometry assets which include the teeth, the saliva, the eye
shell, the left and right eye, the cartilage, the eyelashes and the eye edge.
With everything assembled, the next step is to prepare the assets for fitting.
The first step is to wrap everything to the LOD0 head mesh.
Select the LOD2 head mesh and the additional assets, then select the LOD0 head mesh.
Go to deform and select wrap.
The reason why we wrap LOD0 and LOD2 is because LOD2 makes it easier for fitting and manipulating
polygons.
Subdividing LOD2 results in LOD0.
Once everything has been wrapped to LOD0, the next step is to create a blend shape between
the wrapped assets and the fitted 3D head model.
To blend shape the wrapped assets to the fitted 3D head model, first select the fitted head
model and then select the LOD0 head mesh.
Then go to deform and select blend shape.
As a best practice, you can unlock the normals and soften the edges by selecting the wrapped
geometry, then going to mesh display and selecting unlock normals and soften edge.
Before you create the blend shape, ensure you keep a copy of the eyes as they will become
deformed during the process.
The wrapped eyes will be used as a positional reference later on.
We have just gone over the steps for assembling and preparing the neutral pose assets for
the final fitting process.
In the next section we will continue going over the final fitting process.